استاذ ياسر مرحبا بك من جديد منذ الافتتاح
حتى اليوم همم ما تقيمكم للعمليات الخاصه
بالتنظيف بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى الحمد لله وبدعم
القياده والعمل الدؤوب والمتواصل من فريق
العمل خلال طوال 12 سنه الماضيه همم اقدر
اقول لك قطعنا الان 60% من مشوار البطوله
بنجاح من قطع النظير بشهاده جميع همم
الاعلاميين والمنتخبات المشاركه والاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم الفيفا وما زال هناك
همم مشوار همم اصعب واهم المراحل القادمه
مثل ما ذكر الدوره الثمانيه ودول الاربعه
والنهائي نعد ان شاء الله بعد تجربه مذهله
واستثنائيه حتى همم تكون ختامها مسكين ان
شاء الله كم عدد المشجعين الذين دخلوا الى
الدوله حتى الان مع انتهاء دور ال 16 بلغ
عدد القادمين لدوله قطر همم حوالي 700,000
مشجع من من الخارج من جنسيات مختلفه احتلت
المملكه العربيه السعوديه المرتبه الاولى
ما يقارب ب 100,000 تاليها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومن ثم المملكه المتحده
همم فكما ذكرنا اصبحت دوله قطر وجه همم
سياحيه ووجهه رياضيه للجميع مشجعين كره
القدم
للاستمتاع في همم بطوله استثنائيه من
نوعها حطمه الكثير من الارقام القياسيه
حتى الان رقم مرضي بالنسبه لكم 700,000
مشجع من خارج الدوله
القادمه وكم عدد الذين حضروا المباريات في
الملاعب
قياسيه بجميع مباريات مع انتهاء دور ال16
بلغها حوالي مليونين و860 الف مشجع همم
بطاقه استيعابيه
96% من الطاقه الى الثعابيه للملاعب همم
حيث همم تم همم حضور في مباراه الارجنتين
والمكسيك همم في ملعب الاستاذ يعتبر ثاني
وارحبوا في بطولات كاس العالم
19 يعتبر ثاني اكبر حضور بعد بطوله امريكا
1990 في النهائي واعتقد هذا رقم قياسي
يحسب همم لبطوله كاس العالم وهي فيفا ذكرت
هذا الموضوع بطبيعه الحال بانه كان رقم
قياسي ما ابرز التحديات سيد جمال التي
واجهتكم على الصعيد التنظيم والضيرات
بدء من همم قطر شرف الاستضافه لكاس العالم
في 2010 كانت هناك الكثير من التحديات
بدءا من همم الانتهاء من مشاريع البنيه
التحتيه الخاصه في بطوله كاس العالم
والمرافق همم الحيويه مثل همم شبكه الطرق
والمترو والمطار حمد الدولي ولله الحمد تم
الانتهاء من الجميع هذه المشاريع في وقتها
المناسب وقبل بطوله كاس العالم حيث تم
تجربه جميع هذه المنشات همم في بطولات
سابقه وكانت لنا اكبر همم تحدي ان نجربها
ونشوف نقف على همم الاخطاء والسلبيه حتى
يتم تدارتها في بطوله كاس العالم وهذا ما
حصل لله الحمد في الفتره الاخيره فكان
التحدي مثل ما ذكرنا اللي هي البنيه
التحتيه والانتهاء منها تم الانتهاء من
جميع الملاعب قبل عام من البطوله بعد ذلك
التشغيل العمليات التشغيليه ان نقيم بطوله
في نطاق جغرافيق مثل دوله قطر لم ولن يتم
همم حدوثه في بطولات كاس العالم همم من
قبل همم فكان التحدي ان تكون اربع مباريات
في اليوم بدء من الساعه 1:00 الى الساعه
10:00 ليلا كان تحدي بالنسبه للفيفا وتحدي
بالنسبه للدوله المستطيلفه من ثلاثه
المواصلات من عمليه نقل الجماهير من والى
الملاعب فهل التحديات كانت همم
عائق ولكن لله الحمد لله الخطط التي
وضعناها مع الشركاء الاستراتيجيين في جميع
القطاعات الحيويه في الدوله ساعه بشكل
كبير عند نوصل الى خطا مث وتم تطبيقها في
الادوار للمضاد واثبتها نجاحها حيث تم نقل
ما يقارب حوالي 11 مليون همم رحله في
الفتره السابقه همم في اليوم الواحد عندنا
650 الى 700,000 راكب يستخدم كافه
المواصلات سواء الباصات او المترو او
النقل العام فكانت العمليه سلسه همم لم
تكن هناك اي ازدحامات مروريه تذكر في همم
داخل همم المدينه وهذا شيء ان كان يحسب
يحسب على التخطيط والدعم المستمر من همم
القياده